so over the last 10 years there have
been enormous changes running through
the computer industry we've seen the way
up and we've seen the web transitioning
through the cloud computing we've seen
multi-core computing we've seen the rise
of social computing yet the way that
programmers have been working with
computers with the programming languages
they've been using in many ways hasn't
changed in the last 10 or 20 years
programmers today have to explain to the
machine how to get things done but we
don't want that we want them to be
described the machine what gets done
let's take an analogy when you go into a
coffee shop you don't instruct the
person behind the counter exactly how to
make a coffee you don't tell them to do
the grinding and maybe put through the
espresso machine and do the milk and
foam the milk it and at the same time
you're getting the cup ready and then
once everything's in order bring the
coffee / you operated the more
declarative level you say I'd like a
coffee please and that's how we want
programmers to work too we want them
describing solutions to problems to the
these modern problems in simple and
declarative ways your coffee sir thank
you so we're not just talking about
programmers here we're also talking
about analysts and scientists and
mathematicians and designers and all
these people need to be able to describe
solutions to problems in terms of the
way that they are thinking they need to
be able to tell the computer simply what
they want to achieve so at microsoft
research we've developed a new way of
talking to computers and that's a
programming language called F sharp an F
sharp is a new functional programming
language and it's simple and it's
succinct and it's highly expressive and
it's got inbuilt constructs for
describing solutions to parallel
programming problems and working with
data from the web and working with data
from the cloud so with F sharp people
can write simple code to solve complex
problems
the game that you see in the background
is called the path of gold it is the
first game on the xbox 360 that actually
runs f sharp code go is said to have
originated over 4,000 years ago in China
the game is deceptively simple to play
it only takes minutes to learn the rules
but you can keep improving your skill
over a lifetime it is one of the most
complex and deep board games there is
many people think of chess as a
challenge to artificial intelligence
however the strongest chess player today
is not a human it's a computer the story
for go is completely different by far
the strongest players today are still
humans if you think about a chess game
in a typical situation you will have
about 20 or 30 legal moves you can make
that allows you to build brute force
strategies that actually go ahead and
explore all of the possible fictitious
games that you could play from any point
on if you were to try to do the same for
go you would miserably fail and go you
are going to have about 200 moves you
can make so the universe of possible
games of Go that you can play is
enormous it is way larger than the
number of atoms there is in the universe
and so if you wanted to let a computer
explore all that universe of different
games you could play it would take
literally millions and millions of years
writing the AI engine in f-sharp was a
very straightforward process it was
literally translating the mathematical
algorithmic ideas into code in a very
very natural way using the immense
expressive power that the language has
to offer today we are able to ship a
game of Go that offers a very very
compelling AI in fact I haven't been
able to bid it myself yet
in f-sharp we've made a programming
language the not only developers but
architects and analysts and
mathematicians and scientists can use
and we want to give these people the
tools to solve complex problems using
their intelligence and their creativity
and their imagination